former Eagles quarterback led them to a
Super Bowl and former ESPN NFL analyst
Ron Jaworski joining us hi jaws how are
you today Dan it was a late night it was
a good night
did the Eagles deserve to get booed at
the end of the first down I know that
was just you know I think in a big
overreaction I think it was a
combination of you know some some
questionable calls by the officials the
team not playing that well but I thought
it was an extraordinary evening you know
I got there about five o'clock last
night I was out and actually out in the
parking lot with some of the fans just
kind of getting a feel for you know how
the crowd was going to be and I mean an
hour before kickoff Dan the place was
packed every seat was taken
certainly a great ceremony put on by
Jeffrey Lurie and the Eagles and
celebrating that Super Bowl victory but
I thought it was just an electric
evening I remember the last time we
talked and this was the Monday after the
Eagles won the Super Bowl in Minneapolis
and it brought you to tears yeah when
you wait as long as Eagles fans and
former Eagle players waited to win a
World Championship there there certainly
was a incredible feeling an emotional
feeling and you know it was kind of just
the way I felt and it's you know I've
always been kind of an emotional guy you
know I guess I was trained by Dick
Vermeil and you know we have a great
passion for the game I have a great
passion for you know the Eagles the city
of Philadelphia and then and as you know
Dana I love the game of football so it
kind of all came out on your show the
day after the Eagles victory you can see
jaws on NFL Network doing segments
called film sessions coming up this
season blood low film sessions consist
of Dan you know I'm a walk in the film
room you know since 1990 and I retired
I've maintained an office at NFL Films
it's where I do all my tape study and
breakdowns and I try to drill down on
the game rather than a lot of the
superficial things that most people like
to talk about and this year I'm going to
do what we call it you know film
sessions which are going to be film
breakdowns and drilled down on why plays
work why they don't work why teams won
why they lost really fun when X is an
old perspective and I've kind of hung my
hat on that throughout my career is
doing the drill-down football all right
if you're gonna be breaking down the
Falcons red zone offense what do you
think you're gonna be seeing that and is
it any different than what we saw last
year with the Falcons I mean that game
was a replay of the playoffs of a year
ago the Falcons once again with it with
a chance to win the football game inside
the red zone
with a great receiver like Julio Jones I
I just think you have to do things to
get him in a position to make plays you
know when you put them in that inside
slot receiver and you know I don't want
to start knocking Steve Sarkisian but
when you've got a may sound that way but
when you've got a guy like Julio Jones
you've got to move them around you've
got to give him some some other options
to line up and he put them inside you're
always gonna get double-teamed not eight
when you throw those when you put them
to the outside what's the number one
thing they do they throw that back
shoulder fade to him you know it's been
successful at times but against the
Eagles they just seem to have it pat but
you know and just in a quick review of
that game I thought the Eagles defensive
line really got Matt Ryan off a spot and
got him rattled early and Matt's a lot
better than he played last night but
give credit to that Eagles defense what
about Nick Foles what do you expect to
see from him while he fills in for
Carson woods you know Nick like every
quarterback in this league loves to have
that security blanket his security
blanket when he played for explosive
plays with al Shawn Jeffery he is out
and will be out probably for a couple
more weeks and you could just see the
deep passing game was not there they
were getting nothing down the field it
was a Dinkin dunk short passing game and
without Sean Jeffrey I know Nick loves
to you know chuck it down the field a
few times and you know stretch that
defense but he didn't get the
opportunity to do that and he never did
Nick never got in his comfort zone
either the Eagles didn't run the ball as
effective as you need to although their
yards per carry may look good I don't
think it was the kind of running game
that offensive line that they're gonna
be real happy about but I don't worry
about Nick I really don't I think he's a
terrific player I've got it bother me as
there was a curse it was one of the more
the clunker said he normally does not
put up we're talking to Ron Jaworski and
you can
see jaws NFL film says he's gonna have a
segment called film sessions this year
breaking down game footage also I'm
wondering about this does Carson Wentz's
return depend on what their record is
going to be or how Foles is playing or
is it just when Carson Wentz is healthy
he's coming back
III would think your your last response
would be correct when he's healthy he'll
be back you know there's no sense to
rush him back he is going to be the
Eagles quarterback for the next decade
what does a game or two mean you have a
very capable backup quarterback Nick
Foles a Super Bowl MVP everyone knows
what he is capable of doing there's no
need to rush Carson Wentz back when he's
healthy the medical staff I believe will
alert the the ownership and how heroes
men and say hey he's ready to go they'll
go to Doug and say Doug we got clearance
let's put him on the field there's no
need to rush him back yeah it feels like
there is this rush that you know he's
not gonna be ready for the opener now he
may miss a couple of games and I'm
thinking man I hope he misses a couple
more games that he does take extra time
for this if you're looking big-picture
then then be cautious here there's no
that's why you kept Nick Foles
because you didn't think Carson Wentz
was gonna be ready absolutely right I
mean the Cleveland Browns dangled the
33rd pick in this past year's draft in
front of the Eagles to try to get Nick
Foles and they made an astute decision
of saying hey you know we don't know the
long-term availability of Carson Wentz
let's keep Nick around so we do have
that security blanket and you know I
think it was the right decision and and
you know Carson understands this as well
and they have they have a great locker
room they have a strong relationship
when I'm talking about
Carson Wentz and Nick Foles say they
play for each other they respect each
other it's a very healthy relationship
and trust me Dan and you know this as
well you've go to this game for a long
time it's not always that way so it's a
healthy relationship in Philadelphia how
would you react if you're a teammate and
lay beyond bail with this holdup I would
be upset and quite honestly I you know
we are you know I don't want to hear
from his agent and his attorney and they
you know I've been around this league
since 1973 and yet we all know it's a
business but but I've always felt that
the honor is to play with my teammates
and it's not like he's getting chump
change you know I'm he's making a good
living I think you need to be there with
your players for your players football
is the consummate team game when you
start putting the individual accolades
and salaries in front of the team game
it's hard to be successful and Le'Veon
Bell is putting his Pittsburgh Steelers
in a box right now they're gonna have to
make some hard decisions and and they
got a you know they got to make
decisions about the team and as we hear
from a lot of coaches there is no I in
team and this is going to rock the
Steelers a little bit I believe give me
a team that you're nervous about this
year hey how about this one you want a
shocker the Cleveland Browns the
Cleveland Browns one I think they're
gonna win eight games this year in four
months bring me back you could either
pack I like what I'm seeing in Cleveland
I can't wait to to see some
regular-season tape and break them down
but boy may miles Garrett I mean he had
a tremendous preseason
I mean it's this guy he's going to be
special and Tyrod Taylor is a very
steady quarterback they won't lose games
with Tyrod Taylor because of the
quarterback position and obviously down
the road you got a good young
quarterback in Baker Mayfield look out
for the brownies what team do you see on
the downslide heading down the escalator
the one team that that concerns me a
little bit is the Baltimore Ravens and
there's been an incredible turnover but
they still have Joe Flacco I think we're
gonna find out a lot about the Baltimore
Ravens early because they play the
Cleveland Browns and they play the
Cincinnati Bengals so I think we finally
er if there's a team damn I'm a I
haven't bought into it I'm a big Flacco
guy but he's been banged up the last
couple years I'm a big Harbaugh guy but
they you know they they just haven't
performed well the last couple years so
usually when a team's start descending
they go down for three or four years so
it'll be interesting to see
if the Ravens can pick it up as a former
quarterback and you played at a high
level you led the Eagles to the Super
Bowl when you see Aaron Rodgers what is
it about and other quarterbacks talk
about this as well when they look at
Rodgers there's just something different
about him that we've never seen before
do you look at Aaron rot when you break
down his tape are you seeing something
that nobody else is capable of doing Dan
I think there's something in the water
in Green Bay III really do now that's an
in-depth breakdown is it two guys that
absolutely drove me crazy
throughout my analyst career which goes
back to 1990 after playing for 17 years
is when I used to watch Brett Favre I
would scratch my head how does he get
that ball out how does he completed his
footwork is bad is our mangos bad he's
not coming I mean everything was wrong
yet he'd be throwing a laser so sterling
sharp you know not the same thing with
Aaron Rodgers you'll watch Aaron he's
got two feet up in the air at times is
his arm angle he's not over the top he's
thrown it's sidearm it'll throw it
behind his back he'll do anything to get
a completion so what I when I think of
those two guys they are the aberration
to me to how you should play the
quarterback position mechanically but
they are both so gifted Brett Favre and
Aaron Rodgers from an armed talent
perspective you've got to love them and
maybe all the Packers are contender just
because of Aaron Rodgers would you
rather have Brady's career Aaron Rodgers
Brady would you rather have barbs career
or Aaron Rodgers oh that's a tough one
my knee-jerk would be Brett Favre
I just loved maybe because of the
charisma that he played with yeah I'm
wondering cuz Rodgers has won Super Bowl
just when it's all said and done and we
all eat you know and when we have a
bottom-line sports society its how many
championships is can Aaron Rodgers be
thought of as one of the top three to
five greatest quarterbacks of all time
with one Super Bowl III think there's
absolutely that that that chance I mean
his his numbers are absolutely
phenomenal and we got to remember he he
sat behind Brett Favre so he lost a
couple years early in his career week
where he could have put up
numbers but quite honestly Dan when I
evaluate quarterbacks you know for you
know III served on this committee to
select the top 100 players Roger Goodell
appointed me this committee which will
be announced next year the top 100
players in the history of the NFL
through the first hundred years this was
really tough but I when I looked at the
quarterback position and evaluated you
know number there are a lot of great
numbers guys I believe the quarterback
position is is more than just numbers I
think it's about winning I think it's
about leadership I think it's about
Championships and I put that very high
into my criteria for evaluating
quarterbacks okay your number one
quarterback of all time is Tom Brady
number two Joe Montana number three
Johnny Unitas number four I can't keep
giving you my list for five so Johnny
Unitas and then I'm not going any
further than that I don't want to get a
call from the Commissioner's Office do
not discuss ah you're gonna have John
Elway is next no I know answered
answered you're too good at this but the
key after that is that's what I want to
know what quarterback okay this is sort
interrupt you okay this is going to be a
great argument when this comes out
because we're DC the the first thing we
go to is the modern-day quarterbacks
because that's what we all see that's
what we all talk about that's what we
envision it's amazing when you bet look
back at the Sammy Boz the Sid Luckman
what these guys did in their era you
know Bill Belichick actually had NFL
Films dig down and pull out some tape of
these guys because he was on the
committee to select the top hundred
players everyone took this very serious
and and you know our prism right now are
the present-day guys there were some
incredible players that did incredible
things you know in the 40s in the 50s
and the 60s and it's hard to evaluate
them but I don't want to disrespect
those guys by just throwing out all the
guys that we were familiar well if you
just did generational and then you said
the best quarterback of an era that
might be interesting and then
we did have that discussion and it was a
very some of them were very heated at
times which is great because you know it
we we all took it very very serious I
select the top 100 players in the first
100 years the NFL it's gonna be just a
magnificent group of players ok you have
an office at NFL Films and I keep
wondering why we don't go back through
the archives and count up all the sacks
that happened didn't we start keeping
sack totals in 1982 I that is correct
okay why are we going back to find out
what the fearsome foursome or purple
people eaters are you know whatever it
might be how many sacks that these guys
how many sacks did Deacon Jones really
have jaws oh my god yes yes but we have
the footage right they didn't you know
that that was the brilliance of NFL
Films and they do I you go into the
archives the vault at NFL Films you know
they have every game I think actually
going back to the first collegiate game
ever played in 1869 it is there now when
I go to my office on Monday I'm gonna go
see Ross head over who now runs NFL
Films there Ross we need to do something
about it Dan Patrick recommends and you
know I would not be surprised somewhere
along the way someone has done that with
the Lawrence Taylor with the Deacon
Jones with a claude humphrey those guys
that didn't get credit for maybe some
sacks before they began to record them
I'll get a six-pack of beer and come
down there and watch film with you jaws
well maybe a 12 good to talk to you jaws
and good luck with NFL Network Thank You
jaws Ron Jaworski NFL Network and the
segment's called film sessions when he
came on and I don't know if we booked
him after the Eagles won or we thought
about booking him prior to the Eagles
beating the Patriots but when jaws came
on and it was early in the morning you
might have been our first guest and he
was just you could see where he he was
just starting to tear up that it meant
that much to him that he went to his
Super Bowl they lost to the Raiders
and jaws is he's Philadelphia and he
just started tearing up for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]